معنا الان علي الباشا مراسل فونسون كانت
في طهران اهلا بك علي دن الاضراب يتواصل
في عده مدن ايرانيه لليوم الثالث على
التوالي كيف هي هذه التعبئه هل هناك
متابعه لهذا الاضراب واي القطاعات الاكثر
تضررا وفي غضون ذلك وهناك ربما زياره
مرتقبه لرئيس ابراهيم رئيس الى جامعه
طهران اليوم ما تزامنا مع الاحتفال بيوم
الطالب
السلطات الايرانيه حقيقه حاولت جيده منع
ااا تنفيذ هذا الاضراب العام في الاسواق
الايرانيه خلال الايام الماضيه ومرت
العديمه عبر المؤسسات النقابيه العديد من
الرسائل من فوق الطول احيانا ومن تحت
الطاوله احيانا تحمل الكثير من التهديدات
والتحذيرات لكل التجار الذين يشاركون في
عمليه الاضراب هذه وفي مقدمه هذه الرسائل
هو تشميع مطعم ومحل لبيع المجوهرات تعود
ملكيتهما الى اسطوره كره القدم الدولي
الدولي السابق علي همم لكن حقيقه كل هذه
المحاولات لم ااه تكون
الصور التي وصلت عبر مواقع التواصل
الاجتماعي تشير الى ان طيف واسعا من
التجار في عدد كبير من المدن والمحافظات
الايرانيه همم استجاب لهذه الدعوات وصور
التي وصلت ايضا تثبت ان الكثير من الاسواق
المركزيه في عدد كبير من المدن الايرانيه
حقيقه لم تمارس نشاطتها التجاريه خلال
الايام الثلاثه الماضيه ايضا كان هناك خلل
في الدوام في بعض الجامعات والمدارس همم
الايرانيه بطبيعه الحاله السلطات
الايرانيه تؤكد ان همم التجار الذي نستجاب
لهذه الدعوات
ناتج
استجاباتهم لهذه الدعوات الناتجه عن
تلاقوها من منتصفهم بممثل الشغب بانه سوف
يستهدفون تجارتهم ومحالهم التجاريه في حال
لم يستجبوا هذه الدعوات لكن همم الروايه
الاخرى الطرف الاخر يؤكد ان التجار رغم
انهم تلقوا تحديدات رسميا من قبل السلطات
الايراني
في الايام العاشره الماضيه لكن يوم امس
واليوم الذي سبقه كان هناك مظاهرات في عده
نقاط في العاصمه الايرانيه وايضا في عدد
من المدن والمحافظات الايرانيه رغم ان هذه
كانت همم
باعداد محدوده وتمت السيطره عليها بشكل
سليم من قبل امريكا
التفاصيل شكرا لك